[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voir mes petits amis
mais qui est ce qui pleure c'est
sûrement un bébé capricieux pas trop en
tout cas ces villes je crois que c'est
poopy la poupée de pas preneur si c'est
elle qui la grande rade un apparat de
l'agro dreux patrons m'ont le jeune
homme et voilà c'est une annonce de très
jeunes n'y croient pas
j'ai mis de côté tous les ans et tous
les rois bonsoir je viens gros dés le
bébé qui fera qu'après son où es-tu le
cpie pas bonnes à lui fait sa toilette
dans la salle de bain à l'élan ma petite
fille ni la la que gros chagrin bon
voilà des façons de crier quand on vous
fait sa toilette au territoire anigo
sera bien qu'elle a fini père et elle va
s'endormir bien sagement bon si c'est
comme ça je vais jouer aux cartes avec
nicolas c'est ça il ne fait pas de bruit
pendant que jean donat poopy chéri
ma poupée jerry ne veut pas dormir petit
enjeu mien tu me fait souffrir fermeté
12 y ait des yeux de saphir d'orpi d'or
dans
où je vais sévir
il faudrait je crois pour te rendre sage
à mantoue de soi de riches comme ça
tu voudrais des rouges à ton clair des
cas des bijoux d'or fin et mille autres
choses
mapou péché
ne veut pas dormir petit ange bien tu me
fait souffrir ferme t12 yeux des yeux de
saphir d'or poopy nos dents
où je vais sévir
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais avec toi nicolas ollier
au lieu de faire un bruit pareil tu va
réveiller ma poupée aux mollahs on n'a
plus joué en plein calme son silence
n'est qu'à ya quatre ans chaque fois
mois toujours est la poupée avec pape
rebelles mentorat leur mal à aller on ne
vous disputez plus c'est fini il faut
dormir une nuit les enfants là
j'éteins la lumière
[Musique]
bonne nuit poopy un nicolas bonne nuit
dormait bien
[Musique]
apprenez la raison il est l'heure de
dormir les enfants à te voilà mauvais
joueur me patron semi colloque ces
nounours qui n'est pas un bon joueur il
faut savoir perdre en gardant le sourire
je vais seul patron allons en route
nounours bonne nuit des enfants
et lorsque vous jouez avec vos amis ne
fait surtout pas comme nounours et
nicolas ne vous chamailler pas je ne le
ferai plus prompt
bonne nuit
e
[Musique]